bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en quelques minutes voici les
titres de ce jeudi 5 novembre
depuis le retour du confinement les
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur ne peuvent plus accueillir des
étudiants dans leurs locaux les cours
doivent désormais se dérouler à distance
rencontre avec un jeune yvelinois qui
suit son cours depuis chez lui et focus
sur les adaptations mise en place à
l'université versailles saint quentin et
dans les écoles 3e et à l'estaca en
novembre on arrête de fumer c'est le
défi est lancé chaque année par le mois
sans tabac 4 semaines pour remplir cet
objectif avec une aide proposée l'an
passé trente mille franciliens s'étaient
inscrits à l'opération
et puis le ski club de saint quentin en
yvelines installe à guyancourt recherche
ces nouveaux incubés elle les porteurs
de projets peuvent se porter candidat
pour l'intégrer en 2021 explications
mais avant de développer ses titres ses
révélations de nos confrères du parisien
à propos de l'assassinât de samuel pâtit
dans un article paru aujourd'hui le
journal dévoile le contenu de l'audition
des deux collégiens qui avait désigné le
professeur d'histoire géographie aux
terroristes le 16 octobre dernier à
conflans sainte honorine
elle leur récit montre qu'il semble
avoir été dépassés par la situation
malgré malgré un mauvais pressentiment
contre la somme de 300 euros il avait
accepté de divulguer des informations
sur samuel pâti à l'assaillant qui
affirmait vouloir je cite venger dieu
frappé l'enseignant l'humilier le forcer
à s'excuser après les caricatures montré
en classe et jamais je n'aurais imaginé
qu'ils le tuent qui le décapite ça
déclaré l un des deux mineurs aux
enquêteurs avenue qu'aveuglé dit-il par
l'appât du gain facile ces collégiens de
14 et 15 ans en classe de 4e et de 3e
sont pour rappel émises en est mise en
examen pour complicité d'assassinats
terroristes ils risquent jusqu'à 20 ans
de prison
[Musique]
l'actualité c'est bien sûr le
confinement depuis le déclenchement de
cette mesure voici une semaine les
universités et écoles supérieures ont dû
cesser leurs activités en présentiel
étudiants et professeurs tentent malgré
tout de maintenir un lien à distance l
objectif assurer un maximum le programme
de l'année le reportage de michael et
demi d'euros et de patrick jacques de
dixmude depuis leur confinement loïc est
de retour à voisins le bretonneux cet
étudiant en deuxième année de prépa
ingénieurs à caen est revenu chez ses
parents il suit ses cours à distance
depuis le 30 octobre dernier
mon emploi du temps est maintenue en
fait j'ai exactement les mêmes emplois
du temps que si j'étais en présentiel
donc je kouba mes journées vont être un
peu pareil quand je vais avoir des arts
de trous je vais travailler mais td de
mon côté c'est vraiment un même type de
journée que je pouvais avoir avant une
organisation que le jeune homme de 19
ans espère provisoire il compte
reprendre les cours en présentiel dans
les prochains mois là tout seul devant
son écran c'est dur de rester concentré
surtout quand des fois on à la matinée
on a trois heures et demie du courant
visiophone juste devant son écran
écouter le prof dans le bâtiment de
droit de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 3000
étudiants ne sont pas présent non plus
sur site depuis le confinement
la plupart des enseignants donnent des
cours en télétravail d'autres préfèrent
l'atmosphère d'un amphithéâtre même vide
c'est le cas de ce professeur il donne
un cours à huit clos une première dans
sa carrière débutée en 1976 ça peut
faire un peu un petit peu étrange dans
les premières secondes
mais très vite tout de suite là la
mécanique habituelle reprend et je parle
à la salle comme si mes étudiants et
était lent ça ne me change pas pas grand
chose en réalité
j'espère surtout que pour eux ça ne
change pas trop de choses non plus car
ils sont à l'autre bout de de la caméra
aujourd'hui 350 élèves suivront ce cours
de 3h à distance ça peut être tout à
fait nouveau et intéressant comme
complément est-ce que ça doit remplacer
la présence physique
je n'en suis pas persuadé et
personnellement je reste attaché au
cours corps présents comme on dirait
devant une juridiction à cause de
l'interactivité
les universités ne rouvriront pas avant
minimum trois semaines la date du
déconfinement est pour l'instant fixée
au 1er décembre
et pour continuer de parler de cette
thématique deux invités sont avec moi à
distance en visio deux invités qui
représente 2 école basée sur le
territoire yvelinois il ya catherine
forveille bonsoir lancement elle
responsable communication et marketing à
l'estaca à l'estaca c'est l'école
d'ingénieurs spécialisés dans la filière
du transport et dans les nouvelles
mobilités il ya un campus sur le sur
paris saclay un qui est basée à montigny
le bretonneux légalement christelle
muñoz avec mon grand soir directrice
générale de 3e paris l'institut
international de l'image et du son qui
est à elancourt votre école forme aux
métiers de l'audiovisuel du son du
cinéma du jeu vidéo ou encore du
spectacle vivant
justement première question pour vous
comment vous êtes vous adapté à la
troisième on n'imagine pas forcément
aussi à des cours avec des moyens
techniques l'utilisation de matériel on
pense aux aux caméras est ce que tous
les cours sont à distance où vous avez
pu maintenir tout de même quelques
travaux dirigés puisqu'on sait que le
premier ministre a autorisé la tenue de
quelques travaux dirigés
il ya en effet alors nous étions on va
dire un petit peu préparés suite déjà la
première vague déjà être en mesure et en
gros surtout en capacité de pouvoir
garantir cette continuité pédagogique
donc nous avions d'ores et déjà aménagés
nos plannings surtout ce qu'ils sont
enfin sur tout ce qui était cours
théoriques de manière à ce qu'ils
puissent être effectivement dispensés en
dix ans ciel et ceux de la fin du
premier vingt du premier confinement
jusqu'à la fin de ce confinement et
jusqu'au début de celui-ci est
effectivement le suite aux annonces du
premier ministre nous avons la possible
de pouvoir dispenser des cours
techniques en présentiel bien évidemment
en mesurant les jauges donc il est
évident que sur les plateaux s'il s'agit
d'un du spectacle vivant mais également
notre plateau radio télévision et bien
nous conservons la distanciation sociale
des gestes barrières tout un nombre
d'ustensiles destiné à faire en sorte
que effectivement la sécurité et
l'hygiène soit bien respectée et bien
sûr en limitant toujours le nombre
d'étudiants par travaux dirigés ou
parcours en pratique des travaux dirigés
avec le respect des gestes-barrières les
images que l'on a vues sont des images
bien sûr d'art chiffres qui ont été
tournés avant cette période de crise
sanitaire c'est pour ça qu'ils n'avaient
pas forcément de masques du côté des
stocks à quelles adaptations avez vous
adopté alors nous de la même manière on
avait alors on avait fait une rentrée en
présentiel on avait eu à coeur
d'accueillir tous nos étudiants assez
rapidement au bout de trois semaines on
s'est mis en formation hybride de
manière à accueillir les étudiants par
2000 groupe
un jour sur deux donc il y avait déjà
pas mal de d'équipement et
d'investissement qui avait été fait pour
préparer cette phase de cette ce passage
au mode distant ciel donc aujourd'hui
évidemment on est en sang cours sont
distants ciel on a quelques heures nous
sur c'est vrai que sa route c'est moins
difficile qu'à troisième on a quand même
beaucoup de cours qui peuvent être faits
en ligne de manière satisfaisante même
certains tp par exemple les tp
d'électronique de modélisation on met à
disposition les logiciels pour les
étudiants ils peuvent le faire en ligne
par contre évidemment nous c'est la
question de dtp expérimentaux tout ce
qui est mécanique physique qu'il a pour
le coup on besoin de matériaux
spécifiques
donc là on a fait des demandes de
dérogation donc il ya le processus c'est
qu'on demande une dérogation rectorat et
qui nous a qu'eux qui va nous accorder
on espère les dérogations pour pouvoir
accueillir les étudiants en petits
groupes pour cet été la crise allemagne
hausse 4 il faut reparler de moyens mis
en place qui a été difficile de
s'adapter vous là
10 toutes les deux l'adaptation s'est
faite deux écoles est ce que ça a été
difficile à mettre en place
là c'est jamais simple 1 3 m/s ses 1500
étudiants en simultané qui travaille
effectivement sur des métiers où le
contact et où la manipulation est
importante un ça représente 70 %
quasiment de leur enseignement
donc il est évident que ça nécessite
derrière mécanique à la fois dans la
gestion des plannings à la fois dans la
gestion de tout ce qui va être comme je
le disais tout à l'heure
ustensiles de sécurité effectivement
d'adaptation à la fois des locaux de la
circulation du matériel etc
maintenant on a été quand même assez
préparés comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure sur la première vague pour
effectivement bien anticiper tout en
maintenant nous rentrée également nous
aussi en pressant enfin en présentiel
c'était important ce contact est quand
même très important et surtout renforcer
en tout cas ce lien quelqu'un de très
important le lien social parce que nous
intégrons chaque année des jeunes qui
sont primo entrants et qui sortent du
bac qui arrive dans un univers qui est
un univers nouveau ils vont travailler
sur des savoirs qui sonde et à voile
c'est qu'ils sont des savoirs très
technique
donc il est important malgré tout
d'avoir ce contact avec eux donc les
rentrées était très importante pour nous
en présentiel et effectivement la mise
en place dudit essentielle a été on va
dire assez aisé parce qu'on avait déjà
vécu ce premier confinement et là de
façon beaucoup plus lourde puisque
effectivement là il n'était pas du tout
tolérer la possibilité pouvoir dispenser
des enseignements techniques très
rapidement il reste 40 secondes à un
petit tour d' écran interposé ce que
cette période va vous maintenant vous
pousse à réfléchir à l'avenir est ce que
ça va faire évoluer les méthodes de
pédagogie où vous comptez revenir en
100% présentiel une fois que cette crise
sera derrière nous khatri forveille
alors je pense que les choses avaient
avait déjà évolué en amont chez nous on
avait un centre d'innovation pédagogique
qui travaillait déjà à la mise en place
de qcm en ligne de vidéos en ligne
il y avait déjà des outils qui avait été
développé évidemment
à donner un coup de boost est donc
évidemment je pense que ça va faire
évoluer certaines pratiques mais
évidemment le présentiel reste très
important pour l'essentiel des cours
mais avec une ouverture effectivement et
on a sans doute progressé plus
rapidement qu'on aurait fait son
confinement
c'est ce mot nyos très rapidement eh
bien je pense qu'en tout cas cette crise
nous apprend l'agilité dont il faut
faire enfin dont il faut savoir faire
preuve notamment dans l'est dans le
secteur de l'enseignement est aussi nous
dans le secteur de l'audiovisuel donc je
pense que elle est porteuse de leçon est
que quoi qu'il en soit huile distant
ciel est important est à intégrer bien
évidemment dans l'eau modalités
pédagogiques mais le présentiel reste et
demeure malgré tout extrêmement
important à la fois pour le lien social
qui est quand même très important c'est
quand même des métiers où il est
important de se côtoyer où il est
important d'échanger donc mais malgré
tout je pense qu'il faut aussi savoir
s'adapter et que le distanti elle a
quand même toute sa place dans
l'enseignement eh bien merci d'avoir été
avec nous christelle monier hausse pour
3 yes et catherine forveille pour
l'estac a al'inverse que ce soit dans
les écoles maternelles primaires au
collège et au lycée les cours peuvent se
poursuivre dans l'ain cadre normal mais
avec un protocole sanitaire renforcée
protocole jugé pourtant insuffisant par
plusieurs professeurs ce jeudi à un
mouvement de grève a touché plusieurs
collèges et lycées du secteur du mantois
ils ont à débrayer des enseignants qui a
dénonce de mauvaises conditions
sanitaires l'absence de gel
hydroalcoolique des classes bondées
ces grévistes demandent à l'éducation
nationale de pouvoir accueillir les
élèves davantage en 2000 groupe et du
côté du collège de la vaucouleurs à
mantes-la-ville une opération collège
mort est prévue demain vendredi
le ton est même monté notamment du côté
des lycées de mantes la jolie où il y
avait plusieurs blocus lycéen une
barricade enflammée sur la route à
proximité du lycée rostand à
saint-exupéry est 200 lycéens mené un
mouvement pacifiste depuis le début de
la semaine pour protester contre le
protocole sanitaire mais des
perturbateurs sont venus en venir mais
le mouvement cherchant l'affrontement
avec les forces de l'ordre
plusieurs échauffourées ont eu lieu des
jets de projectiles la police a dû faire
usage de gaz
aux gènes pour disperser la foule et les
affrontements se sont poursuivis ensuite
dans le quartier du val fourré en
novembre et c'est l'occasion de se
lancer un défi c'est le mois sans tabac
4 semaines pour arrêter de fumer avec
l'aide de tabacologue d'un kit de i
coaching et d'une communauté très
développé l'année dernière plus de 30000
franciliens s'étaient inscrits au défi
interview express avec mélanie poker
[Musique]
collectif national lancé depuis 2016
c'est une initiative du ministère des
solidarités et de la santé en
partenariat avec l'assurance maladie et
santé publique france donc voilà ce
challenge invite toutes les personnes
qui le souhaitent à arrêter de fumer
pendant un mois tous ensemble à moi
c'est cinq fois plus de chances de
réussir son sevrage tabagique par la
suite si il y avait éventuellement en
rechute au moins vous aurez pu prendre
conscience que vous êtes capable de vaud
de vous passer de certaines cigarettes
ou de toutes les cigarettes donc plus de
réussite pour une prochaine tentative
[Musique]
ce qu'on a pu constater lors du premier
confinement c'est que ça aussi et est
une période propice aux changements de
comportements individuels
nous avons fort à parier que toute la
solidarité et les encouragements au
quotidien par exemple sur la communauté
facebook n'en seront que plus présent et
renforcer cette année donc profitez en
pour aller trouver toute la motivation
et le soutien dont vous avez besoin dans
l'actualité également l'île de france
présentait ce matin sont un nouveau plan
de mobilisation pour l'emploi vous le
savez le chômage a explosé depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire
l objectif soutenir environ 790 me le
demandeur d'emploi de la région avec une
difficulté cette année je vous le disais
un sel de cette crise sanitaire les
précisions de célia gâte son goût pour
accélérer le retour à l'embauché des
demandeurs d'emploi d'île de france la
région a proposé plusieurs actions sur
le territoire francilien des secteurs en
tension ont besoin d'employés comme ceux
de la santé et de la sécurité et pour
que ces secteurs deviennent plus
attractifs et que les formations
deviennent plus attractives nous avons
décidé de verser une prime
supplémentaire de 1000 euros qui va
s'ajouter aux rémunération habituelle
des stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle
ces formations sont à retrouver sur
l'application oriane forme pro ou sur le
site
oriane point info et pour les jeunes
demandeurs d'emploi beaucoup sont
freinés dans leurs recherches car ils
n'ont pas le permis de conduire
la région va donc leur proposer net nous
estimons qu'il ya près de soixante mille
jeunes en insertion en ile-de-france qui
pourraient bénéficier de cette aide
pourra passer leur permis de conduire
une aide de 1300 euros qui correspond au
prix moyen d'un permis de conduire
dix mille places de formation en
e-learning seront également proposés
dans les métiers qui recrutent notamment
dans le domaine du numérique la région
reçoit des crédits du prix qu plan
régional d'investissement dans les
compétences
elle voudrait les mobiliser pour deux
situations différentes qui ne sont pas
encore débloqué qu'on puisse mobiliser
aussi le prix que je lui demandais à
elisabeth bornes pour les salariés qui
envisagent une reconversion
professionnelle parce que leur emploi
est menacé
on a la possibilité de maintenir dans
des classes théorique des apprentis qui
ne trouve pas
d'ailleurs pour un certain laps de temps
et c'est pas forcément suffisant et donc
nous aimerions pouvoir mobiliser le prix
pour pouvoir faire des formations
complémentaires de nouveaux campus des
métiers et de qualification seront
également ouverts très prochainement
dans le val de marne et dans le val
d'oise pour renforcer les filières santé
et sécurité
c'est l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines le ski cuba lancé sa nouvelle
campagne d'appel à candidatures destinés
aux start-up si vous êtes porteur d'un
projet innovant vous pouvez candidater
pour intégrer la structure en 2021 a
lieu avec plusieurs nouveautés ont fait
le point avec nicolas d'andré
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines va rentrer dans sa quatrième
année d'existence depuis 2010 est le ski
cuba accueilli 41 porteurs de projets
qui ont abouti à la création de 16
start-up un bilan plutôt positif pour
alexandra rosetti la vice présidente en
charge du développement économique à
saint quentin en yvelines
si jamais simple de créer et de lancer
une start up dont quand on a quand même
quelques réussites que ça aboutit on est
on est plutôt content de 2,6 chiffre-là
et le ski cube rentrer dans une seconde
phase de développement avec de nouveaux
services proposés
d'abord le développement et
l'approfondissement des expertises
apporter aux start-up accueilli et
ensuite le renforcement du programme
d'accélération
on écoute à nouveau alexandra au rosetti
qui nous détaille ces dispositifs
c'est un accompagnement plus poussées en
matière je suis en matière juridique en
matière ressources humaines en matière
financière c'est à dire qu'on va faire
appel à un éventail d'intervenants
extérieurs un petit peu plus poussé pour
être techniquement plus précis on va
dire
l'autre volet c'est l'accélérateur qui
lui va permettre va nous permettre
d'accompagner des entreprises qui sont
créées qui sont déjà maintenant sur une
vraie dynamique mais qui ont besoin
d'être soutenue en termes de
développement commercial en termes de
relations commerciales voient même voire
même en arrivant à se tourner vers
l'étranger
autre nouveauté le ski cub souhaite
aussi s'ouvrir aux start-up étrangères
l'objectif de cette seconde phase
permettre le d
ben loppement de 27 heures par an et ça
commence dès maintenant avec la nouvelle
campagne d'appel à candidatures lancé le
lundi 2 novembre si vous avez un projet
que vous souhaitez le développer en vous
installant au ski cube pour bénéficier d
accompagnement et bien vous devez vous
rendre sur ce site internet vous pourrez
télécharger le document de candidature
remplir les différentes informations
demandées et vous avez jusqu'au 3
décembre 2020 l'entreprise dont nous
allons parler maintenant elle est
installée dans l'axé l'air c'est le
centre d'innovation du groupe air
liquide aux loges en josas son activité
la production de diamants de synthèse ca
clients sont notamment saint quentinois
regardez ce reportage de nicolas dont
nous ce sont des diamants créé en
laboratoire de différentes couleurs des
recettes d'alix et gicquel
ce jour-là elle présente ses différentes
créations à cécile da rocha dirigeante
d'une start-up implantée à montigny le
bretonneux jeannard eux c'est une marque
de joaillerie responsables ont créé des
bijoux uniques intemporel éthique et
durable
on s'est intéressés du coup au diamant
créer un laboratoire pour se fournir
cécile da rocha se tourner vers cette
société de production de diamants de
synthèse en laboratoire créé en 2016
elle vient de s'installer dans
l'accélérateur d'air liquide aux loges
en josas
c'est le démarrage de la
préindustrialisation objectifs pour
l'année prochaine produit un mille 500
carats de diamants de synthèse grâce à
ses six réacteurs en installation on
part d'un petit germes de diamants qui
est mono cristallin pour le met dans un
réacteur à placement on va introduire
des gaz du de l'hydrogène moléculaire et
on va produire du méthane on va envoyer
des micro ondes et les micro-ondes vont
créer une décharge électrique dans ce
gaz et on va donc avoir
une production d'atomes de carbone dans
le dans le milieu gazeux ces atomes de
carbone vont permettre la formation du
diamant à partir du germe
ils ressortent sous cette forme là le
premier c'est un diamant brut qui sort
du réacteur comme ça au milieu il ya le
moigno cristal et autour il y à ce qu'on
appelle le poly cristallin qui est noir
on prend le laser de découpe et au corps
ont des tours pour sortir le mono
cristal ensuite on l'envoie chez un
tailleur et le tailleur fait des
merveilles comme le petit diamant qui à
côté le coussin briand qui est champagne
sur le long terme pour cette société
l'objectif est de produire huit mille
carats sur différentes plateformes de
production
et puis dans un instant la rédaction de
tv 60,18 vous propose un nouveau
rendez-vous si on rentrait l'émission
qui vous occupe cependant ce nouveau
confinement une bonne dose de sourire en
cette période difficile
à chaque rendez-vous ses idées pour se
restaurer se dépenser se cultiver se
divertir et aussi apprendre de nouvelles
astuces le touche chez vous car c'est
important il faut rester un maximum chez
vous si on rentrait le rendez-vous de la
rédaction proposée tous les jeudis soirs
du confinement en direct à 18h30 en
replay sur tv 78 points comme voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité belle
soirée à tous avec itv 78
[Musique]